okay so we are doing ex the greate today
um let us
review last class um where we discussed
the father son dynamic between Philip II
and his son Alexander okay we said that
the
father he is
the founder and the Builder of a great
organization and um as such he will have
three particular characteristics unique
to him okay first of all he will
exercise really good
judgment because he's starting with
nothing and he has to build up slowly
his Nation or his organization okay
second thing that we said is he will
promote
Talent okay he will be a very
generous and fair-minded individual who
will Who will actively spot talent and
create a meritocracy Okay the third
thing we said was this person will be
selfless extremely disciplined and this
person will put the greater good before
his or her own
interests okay and that will inspire
loyalty from uh his or her workers or
soldiers we also said the son will be
very different okay because the son is
inheriting this Enterprise or this
nation the sun will focus on expansion
the sun will be a very aggressive risk
taker
okay um second characteristic of the sun
is um because he is under the father's
Shadow he will promote obedience and
loyalty okay promote
loyalty and the final characteristic the
final contrast between the father and
son is um the sun will be very
selfish because the sun will be focused
on personal
Glory the reason why is the sun is
insecure right the sun uh will hear
people in the background in Shadows
Whispering oh everything you've achieved
it's because you're father and so the
son is desperate very anxious to prove
his own self-worth okay so um we see
this dynamic in literature in and in
history in our in our in our own lives
right this is a very common Dynamic now
we said that this would be a this is
really a thought
experiment okay but if you think about
it this is also a analytical
model it's a okay it's a way to
understand the world around us and in an
an anical model we have to test if it's
true or not and if it's true it does two
things okay first first thing it does is
it it
explains does it help us understand
better understand the motivations and
behavior of people around us in last
class we F we focused on for the second
and we um and that really helped us to
understand his motivations and behavior
okay today uh but the second thing it
must do is
predict okay it has to predict the
future if this an anical model that we
have is correct then it will allow us to
predict future events and behavior okay
and that's what I propose today I
propose to use this model to predict the
life of AC the great okay so from this
model we can extrapolate
three um
characteristics of Alexander's Reign
when he takes over as king okay um
what's the first characteristic
of Alexander when he when when he
becomes
king
okay and Eko do you have any ideas of
what he will do as
king exactly okay so the first thing he
we
will um say is that he will focus on
expansion okay he'll be a very
aggressive risk taker
he will take risks that are not
strategically
wise okay that's the first prediction we
can make about him what the second
prediction we can make about him based
on
this exactly we call this a tyrant okay
he's he's become a
tyrant a tyrant is someone who demands
obedience from
everyone okay does that make sense
and so if he's a tyrant what is he what
is he going to do to all these Talent
people that his father
promoted he's going to kill them
right okay he's he's he's going to get
rid of them because he needs to promote
his own people and because he time the
people will um counter his tyranny okay
so we predict he will demand complete
and total obedience from his followers
okay
and what's the third prediction we can
make about him well the third prediction
is that
he the question is will he ever be
happy when will he stop his
ambition never okay so his
ambition is
boundless so these are the three
predictions we can make about Alexander
if he were to become king just based on
our understanding of the father son
Dynamic okay the first is that he will
he will focus on aggressive expansion he
will take risks that his father will not
take okay that's the first thing second
thing is he's going to become a tyrant
who will demand total loyalty and
obedience from his followers and if you
um for his own good speak up and try to
reason with him he will see you as a
threat as as disloyal and as as an enemy
who must be eliminated Okay the third
prediction we can make is his ambition
is boundless he will never stop
expanding he will never stop going to
war okay these These are three
predictions we can make based on this
anal model
okay and it turns
out these three
predictions basically
capture the essence of EX life okay all
right so now I will slowly explain The
Life and Times of action of the
great all right so um any questions so
far okay so we are using this anal model
to understand The Life and Times of exam
the great and what we're doing this
we're trying to see if there are
problems with this model okay all right
so we have to take a very skeptical
attitude we have this prediction model
we're going to use it we're going to
apply it to ex the grade and we're going
to see that on the surface it does
actually capture well or explains well
his life at the same time we want to be
generous and skeptical skeptical okay we
want to ask ourselves is it possible
that we are blinded by our prejudice and
maybe we are being unfair to ACC the gr
okay does that make sense all right so
let's start with the first major event
in a of the Great's life which is the
death of his father in
33c uh BCE okay and alander right now
he's only 20 and when his father dies he
is automatically coronated as king of
the kingdom of
Macedon now I want to explain the
circumstances of Philip's death because
it's very important for us to understand
the sort of
psychology of his son so two years
before um his death Philip actually
remarried okay now um remember that
Macedon is a society that promotes uh
polygamy okay so Philip at this point
already has six or seven wives the
problem is that only one of his wives uh
named
olympas um has given birth to a son and
therefore a he okay the son is Alexander
the other wives have failed to give um
birth to a hear
and it seems Alexander will be anointed
king after the death of his
father so when Philip Mary's uh her name
is um Cleopatra
uidic um it's
extremely controversial okay it sort of
disrupts the political order of
Macedonia the first reason is Cleopatra
you you really see she is actually
Macedonian before
um Philip married foreign wives for
diplomacy reasons and what this means is
if Cleopatra Ur gives birth to a son
this son will be more legitimate be more
legitimate here than Alexander and this
pushes Alexander out of the line of
secession okay so this is
extremely uh controversial and it's like
dynamite almost okay so that's that's
first problem second problem is you
is the wife of one of her's great
generals at
Atlas okay and actually after the
wedding
ceremony um between your DC and Phillip
atus gave a toast and he
said here's a toes and I pray that nadon
will soon have a legitimate hear and
this direct insult to um Alexander okay
the other problem is that atas his
father-in-law is
parmenion who is really Philip's partner
okay the greatest General that macona
has the person in control of the
army okay so it seems like Alexander is
being pushed out of the line of
secession
and um Alexander and his mother Olympia
are both freaking out
okay so in
33c uh 336
BC philli is assassinated by his
bodyguard and no one knows uh who why
this happened okay but we know what
happened afterwards what happened is
first of all
olympas killed EDC and her daughter and
son the son was going to be legitimate
here to the throne now they're all dead
okay that's the first thing that happens
second thing that happens is
atus becomes afraid and he he's about to
Rebel okay and atus again is a general
at this stage at this point paronan is
now the kingmaker right because ponan is
now head of the army he can choose to
support atus his
son-in-law and rebel okay and maybe
become king himself or he can support
Alexander okay and at this point the
faithful decision that caran mix is he
supports Alexander and he kills atus and
atus again is his son-in-law and this
makes Alexander now the legitimate he to
fello he's now king of
ason okay so from this um event we can
surmise some things okay the first thing
we can surmise is um olympas and
Alexander are extremely ambitious right
they will not be pushed aside if they
see any risk to their power they will
act
viciously okay they're not afraid to
kill they will they will they will even
kill the king in order to assure their
power okay that's the first thing the
second thing that's more important for
us is
permanon is absolutely
loyal to
Alexander because if you think about it
he's loyal to the m
of
Phillip
okay Philip promoted ponon to be his
partner and in a show of loyalty and
gratitude peronia now is being loyal to
the son
Alexander okay so that's the first major
event in alander light any questions
about about this
event before I move
on okay so the second thing that happens
is is remember like Philip is now in
charge of this white Kingdom across
Greece and when people hear about his
death uh people start to Rebel okay the
Athenians want to rebel the thians want
to rebel the spaans want to
rebel um and then to the north the lyans
rebel okay so all the there are these
rebellions the first thing that
Alexander does is he mounts this
extremely fast and decisive campaign to
quell all Eternal descent because
ultimately his ambition is to complete
the dream of his father the conquest of
Persia right so he goes to um yria which
is in North uh which is north to uh um
Macedonia and destroys all opposition
next thing he does is he marches against
Greece itself against thieves and
thieves is the main source of opposition
and Spartan and Athens both promised to
send Troop to support thieves the
problem is Alexander gets there really
fast and he lays Siege to thieves and
destroys it completely the next thing
that he does is he decides to Massacre
all the males and enslave all the woman
now this is actually common practice
back then in terms of warfare but this
is not done to Greek cities do you
understand the Greeks consider
themselves
special and so so in 404 BC when Sparta
defeated Athens in the palan war
remember that Sparta did not do anything
Sparta just basically said guys will you
promise not to bother us again and
Athens says we promise that was it okay
so what a the great did destroying
thieves which is one of the great
cultural
centers of the Greek world that was like
basically setting off a nuclear bomb
okay and from then on um the Greeks were
committed to overthrowing Alexander when
the opportunity Rose at the same time
Alexander by doing this by showing this
by showing his
ruthlessness he was able to for now
pacify all uh discontent okay people are
now afraid of him and that's what a
wants he wants
fear okay so now that Eternal descent
has been pacified now that now that um
his uh leadership has been legitimized
he will now embark on the massive
invasion of Persia okay now originally
his father Philip II his dream was a
unified Greek World okay what we call
helenistic okay or the helenic world
because remember at this point uh you
have these Greek polares spread all
across the agian and the Mediterranean
okay in North Africa in Italy uh in Asia
Minor in Anatolia okay and and Philip's
Vision was to unify all these
places but Alexander the Great his
vision was actually to conquer Persia
okay so so he's expanding his father's
uh Vision so he's Landing he lands in
Anatolia which is like modern turkey
with this massive Invasion Force okay
and he's going against the Persian
Empire um the way that the Persian
Empire is as design is it's not really
an Empire it's more like a confederation
or Alliance so the provinal governors
who we call the
satraps they're the ones responsible for
defending their own territory and at
this point uh the the king of King of
Persia his name is Darius III he's not
really bothered by Alexander okay he
doesn't realize that Alexander will will
pose a threat to his rule okay he he
thinks this guy he's like 20 years old
he's an upstart doesn't really matter so
darus doesn't really bother himself okay
but he s an advisor this guy U he's a
Greek
Menan of
RADS so he's Greek and he understands
Greek Warfare and so they have this war
council between the satraps the local
Governors and Men on of roads and what
men Road
proposes is the safest strategy to
defeat Alexander which is basic what we
call a war of
attrition the idea is they will not
encounter not fight Alexander on the
battlefield because Alexander right now
processes the greatest army in the world
right let's not let's not fight him we
will burn all the crops and starve his
troops at the same time what we will do
is we will bribe Athens and spart to
rebel against Alexander And once he's
overextended he has no choice but to go
home
okay the war is over doesn't cost us
anything the SAT trops refuse this plan
because it would mean destroying their
own property okay so Sops are like no we
can overwhelm him so at the Battle of
granticus
um in 334
BCE um Alexander's forces destroy the
Persians okay and this is the first
major battle of this war there'll be
three major battles
what's important for us is during this
battle um Alexander displayed tremendous
recklessness okay he rushed to the front
of the battle he led his calvalry in um
and he was almost overwhelmed okay one
of the SAT traps knocked him down and
One S was about to kill him slash him
okay but then at the last minute a man
named cus black clus the
black comes running in and he slashes he
cuts off the stup's arm thus saving
aer's life all right so at this point
there are two individuals that Alexander
should be most grateful for right
paronan who
basically um he was a keymaker and he
announced that the Army would be always
loyal to Alexander okay and C is a black
who saved Xander's life in battle and
both of these men were individuals
promoted heavily by his father for their
talent okay so basically was his
father's man that saved Alexander so you
you would think exander would be very
grateful to these men
right unfortunately he would end up
killing both men and this would forever
change the course of his life okay all
right so um after the battle of
granticus men of RADS was given complete
freedom
to um do what he wanted okay so Mena
roads tried to stop
Alexander um and when he realized he
couldn't do it because aer's Army was
too powerful men of Road set sail for
Greece he was hoping to bribe Athens and
Sparta to join the war and rebel against
um Alexander and here something that
happens and aand gets really lucky okay
and we will find this in his life he
gets very lucky a lot of of times and
what is it that happens when men of
world set sail for Greece about to and
he's about to unite the Greeks and rebel
against Alexander and remember Athens
and Sparta at this point really hates
Alexander so what
happens he dies okay he gets sick and he
dies and when man of Rose Dies there's
no more contact with the Greek world and
now Persia is left to um basically
defend itself okay the Greeks cannot be
counted on there will be Greek
rebellions against Alexander but they
will be sporadic they will not be
coronated okay so Darius has no choice
but to confront Alexander in two massive
battles so the first massive battle is
in southern turkey Anatolia C the Battle
of Isis okay in 333 BC the Second Battle
will be will happen two years later in
guacola
um in
Mesopotamia and both of these battles um
are about the same okay so I'll explain
what happened in both battles so you can
understand AC strategy of of War all
right so usually in battles there are
three major forces there's something
called the Left Flank okay the center
flank and the right flank and both
armies are like this now in both battles
the Persians were heavily the Persian
the Persians heavily outnumbered the
Greeks two to one okay so it's massive
difference and the calry is usually on
the sides now there are some certain
differences okay the first difference is
the Persian the Persians have one leader
Darius and he's in the center PR
protected by his body guard called The
Immortals The Immortals are the best
troops of the Persians okay the
macedonians have two leaders
permon and alander
Alexander is in charge of the calary
paronian is in charge of the Infantry
the what we call the PHX and in both
battles the same thing happens which is
on the left side darus commits Moses
forces against paronan okay so paronan
is being overwhelmed by Superior numbers
but here the discipline of ponon is just
incredible because even though they're
being overwhelmed okay being outnumbered
and they're about to be all outrun they
hold their ground okay and then in the
right in the center there's so much
conflict that eventually what happens is
there's a small Gap that allows
Alexander to rush to Darius okay
remember Darius is being protected
heavily because he's a king
right and at this point Alexander and
his forces are
overwhelming the Cavalry of Darius and
they're about to close up they're
getting close to Darius and at this
point what Darius does and this is
something you can never do in a in a
battle what does Theus do now and he
does this in both battles Isis and and
uh guala what what does he do now he he
sees ex closing in right but his Left
Flank is about to overwhelm harmonia
what does what does darus do now in both
battles he runs away okay when he does
that
Alexander is now free to go back and
rescue ponan and then the persons flee
okay does that make
sense all right so this is what happens
in both battles Isis and guaga so um now
that you have the basic overview of both
battles let's let's let's Analyze This
to ask ourselves how great a commander
is Alexander okay and I want I want to
make you again make the argument that
he's actually not a great strategist
okay he's a great Soldier he's very
brave but he's not a great strategist
not like his father okay the first thing
I will say is this um when military
historians look at battles they look at
the wrong things right so they're
usually looking at um
Manpower
technology and resources okay what we
call
Wealth right and if we look look at
battles from this land right Manpower
take technology and resources wealth
then we can argue that Persians were
heavily favored in this battle in this
war right we can say that but I think
this is a wrong way to look at a
military strategy I think if you really
want want to understand who who's a
favorite who's the underdog you you have
to look at three different things these
three different things are cohesion the
idea of cohesion is Unity right are
these solders
uh loyal to each other are they friends
with each other okay second thing you
want to look at is
discipline how well trained are these
troops Okay the third thing you want to
look at is idea of
devotion devotion just means how loyal
are they to their
leaders how much purpose do they have in
the battle okay does that make sense and
what what I want what I want what I want
to show you today is but looking at
these three things they give you a much
better overview or analysis of who the
better military is okay so if you just
look at Manpower technology and
resources then clearly the Persians are
the heavy favorites right if you change
your frame of reference and you will
look at cohesion discipline and de
devotion then the masonian are far
superior right because look cohesion
means they have a culture they have a
similar culture right they're all Greeks
whereas the Persians are a multicultural
Empire that don't they don't speak the
same language which means that all these
different units that Darius has they're
basically Fighting by fighting um by
themselves so are not coordinated okay
does that make sense that's the first
thing second thing is the idea of
discipline if you're an Empire the
problem with an Empire is your soldiers
don't fight that many battles right
because you're an Empire no going to
challenge you so these soldiers even
though they have these very expensive um
armor and horses they weren't
disciplined they didn't have experience
in battle whereas Alexander's Army is
Philip's Army and for the past 30 years
all they did was fight battle after
battle against uh the Greeks okay so in
terms of discipline the Greeks are far
superior and and then you look at
devotion um Darius is King why are
people loyal to him because he pays them
right it's profit it's
interest whereas the soldiers under
poman Alexander they love their leaders
right their
leaders um have taken to Victory to lots
of Victories so they're very loyal to
him okay so just in terms of these if
you look just look at cohesion
discipline and devotion we can
predict that Alexander's Army would win
regardless of the strategy okay and now
you can make also make the argument that
the strategy that Alexander employed
right this we will confront the Persians
head on Philip would have thought this
was a stupid idea okay because first of
all you're outnumbered second of all
you're an enemy terrain right you're an
enemy terrain therefore they are able to
deploy the resources much better than
you are okay now the third problem is
this the Third problem is you cannot
afford to retreat you understand there's
no place to
retreat if you if your army ever breaks
right if ponan gets overwhelmed then
you're all dead why take that risk right
also before before both battles isus and
gamola Darius want to negotiate with
Alexander basically darus said I will
give you half my
Empire right that's pretty generous and
Alexander says no I need all of it all
right so historians will tell you that
guacola is this shows the military
prowess of
Alexander and uh but if you analyze it
properly I think you will see there are
lots of problems with a strategy in both
battles okay he was taking risk that he
shouldn't have and he he sacrificed a
lot of men that he didn't really need to
sacrifice for example it was all about
winning the war
right personal Glory whereas Philip was
concerned about the safety and
well-being of his soldiers so Philip
would not have engaged in such a battle
he would have preferred negotiation and
then over time
slowly um overwhelm Persia okay does
that make sense any questions so far
about this
analysis quick question yeah great I can
see this you are
right
y yeah right okay so um um great
question so um actually didn't really
trust the Greeks um the Greeks didn't
consider the macedonians part of the
they didn't consider the maonan is Greek
okay and so when Alexander sent his like
when Alexander developed his invasion
force of Persia there weren that many
Greeks actually in in it was mostly
Macedonia okay does that make sense
right but but you're right if um given
what the what uh a did in thieves he
could not really trust the Greeks
anymore okay he couldn't really trust
the Greeks like switch sides and also
there were a lot of Greek mercenaries
fighting for Darius in this battle U men
of Ro was was Greek okay and he sort of
knew the Greeks really didn't like
Alexander it's more like tribal Army
rather that's right that's right that's
right okay but but again we see this
throughout history where a trial Army
because of cohesion discipline and de
devotion they basically able to conquer
the world right so you
look yeah yeah so so you look at
Muhammad you look at gangas Khan right
and you look at tamland you look at a
lot of people right they were all
trouble armies but because they had
cohesion discipline and devotion they
were able to basically conquer most of
the world before they themselves um uh
devolved into Civil War okay so does
that make sense oh yeah okay any more
questions before I
continue okay
um okay so while Alexander was
campaigning against Persia he was doing
things that sort of annoyed his soldiers
okay so for example
um he conquered Egypt without much
resistance okay so he went to Egypt and
basically the Egyptians hated the
Persians for for for decades for
centuries the Egyptians were trying to
rebel against Persia without success so
when alander came they saw him as a
liberator so Egypt fell without
resistance the first thing that
Alexander does is he takes a trip into
the desert he disappears for weeks he he
goes something call he goes to a place
called The Temple of Zeus um
Aman uh Aman is the highest Egyptian god
and Zeus is the highest Greek god so
there are like a syesis okay so this is
the highest God in the world and this is
found in the isolate Oasis and actually
goes to this Oasis in order to seek
counsel he wants to see his
future and at when he's at the Temple of
Zeus Amon he's told that Phillip is not
really his father
okay Philip is not really his father
actually his two father is take a wild
guess who who the true father
is Zeus Aman right Alexander is the
first Son of God right he's the son of
God he's like Heracles and dynastes he's
actually the Son of God and so when
Alexander returns to his soldiers after
this
Revelation he expects his soldiers to
acknowledge this fact okay so one thing
is um in the Macedonian army there's
there's a lot of uh equality between
soldiers and officers right so if you're
Soldier you are allowed to speak your
mind but now a under
demands if you come into His presence
you must first kiss his feet which is a
Persian custom okay you must first you
must kiss the feet of your king and the
macedonians of course didn't really like
this so now there's growing
concern about the tyranny of Alexander
okay um people like ponan and C as of
black who were promoted heavily by his
father are kind of annoyed basically
Alexander renounced his father Philip's
not really my father I'm really the son
of a God okay Zeus
Amon okay
so okay so now there's going discontent
among his
soldiers does does that make sense so
far and any questions before I move
on is this clear to you
okay all right so um you know in 331 BCE
gamola the Battle of gual happens and
Alexander wins this incredible Victory
against the Persian king Darius Darius
run away but then he's he but then he's
eventually killed by one of his generals
okay and the Persian Empire now is
basically conquered there's no
resistance against Xander anymore
there's some resistance but not
organized resistance okay and at this
point
um Alexander starts being a tyrant okay
so the first
major um sign that he's changing is in
BCE paronian is killed remember paronian
you can argue was a man responsible for
all of Alexander's victories right
because permon is the one who's doing
all the heavy lifting he's being
overwhelmed by most of Persian forces he
stands his ground which allows Alexander
to claim his victory okay in 33 oce
alander orders ponan to be killed and
there's a lot of controversy around what
happened right so I I'll just basically
tell you the basic um facts and then
we'll analyze what happened um
so there's a lot of resentment against
Alexander in the Army and now and then
there are these conspiracies they don't
go
anywhere um but there are these
conspiracies amongst officers to
assassinate
Alexander and one of these
conspiracies um is found out and uh one
of the officers who finds out about this
conspiracy goes to um Pan's son okay and
tells the son hey go tell the king
people are trying to assassinate him the
son per son uh he doesn't think this is
a big deal and he's kind of drunk okay
uh so he does he doesn't he forgets to
tell alander okay the plot is uncovered
and the
sun uh F lius Fus
he's implicated and he's tortured he had
nothing to do with assassination but
he's implicated because he didn't tell
Alexander while he's being tortured he
also confesses to his father being part
of a plot even though there's no
evidence implicating his father in fact
you can make the argument that his
father is completely loyal to Alexander
okay and so just based on this a a forc
confession under torture which is
completely unreliable Alexander in the
Army decide to have ponan killed okay so
an assassin is sent and paronian is
killed now um these are the basic facts
and there's lot of argument about what
happened okay so the most generous
argument the most general generous
interpretation is a didn't want ponan
killed he knows permon ponan is Innocent
but because Alexander was forced to kill
his son Phil fetas actually didn't feel
he had a choice in the matter okay
because pan want might might want
revenge so to maintain
stability uh and peace within the
Army he had to get permanent and killed
okay that's the most generous
explanation but there's another
explanation that makes more sense which
is Alexander has always been jealous of
ponan right because ponan has the most
legitimacy in the army Army troops feel
more loyal to ponan than they do to
Alexander right because they've been
they uh ponan um they're more experience
with ponan than with Alexander and ponan
was responsible for many great triumphs
so Alexander was jealous of
ponon also there were these new young
officers who want to climb the ranks and
to do so they need to get rid of people
like ponan right so maybe the conspiracy
was um a fake conspiracy and it was
organized by these low officers to
implicate fites and then in order to get
rid of uh ponan
okay but regardless of how how you
interpret
this what we do know is after ponan was
killed basically all the shackles all
the restraints on Alexander went away
because there's no one in the AR because
now there's no one in the Army who can
resist Alexander okay there's no one who
who can basically urge restraint and
caution so the next thing that happens
is this in the year
328 clus a black is killed remember ctis
of black is a person who saved A's life
at the Battle of grakis
okay but ctis of black again he is a
loyal officer promoted by his father and
now CL of black has a same Authority as
ponan once had so CL of black is now a
threat to Alexander so what Alexander
does is he basically orders the CL of
black to take some soldiers and go off
to a far away place it's basically Exile
okay ex is basically Exile exiling him
from the main Army and cl of black knows
basically he's finished so before CL of
black is meant to go into Exile they
have a large banquet okay and they're
all drunk and cl of black now is
angry and he gets into a vicious
argument with Alexander and class of
black basically says to Alexander you've
betrayed your people the macedonians
you've come to
Persia and you could only conquer Persia
with our help and now you're turning
into a Persian okay you're adopting
Persian uh Customs like forcing officers
to kiss your feet you're promoting
Persian officers in your
army okay you're turning your back away
from the culture that made you
great then he says something that
really pisses Alexander off what is what
is one thing that you can say to
Alexander that would really piss him off
you in fact he would want to kill you
now EV that You' chiev exander it's
because your father this is not you okay
this conus of Persia it's not you it's
your father it's your father who built
this amazing army it's your father who
developed this plan to conquer Persia
okay Alex gets so angry that he's about
to Lunge at clus of black okay but
before he can do so his
bodyguard surrounds him and stops him
and they pull away his sword and so this
makes us think he's been doing this a
lot okay Alexander the Great gets drunk
a lot and kills a lot of people
basically um um and then cler black he's
taking out of the room but cler black is
so strong he forces himself back in the
room he starts to continue arguing
against
Alexander Alexander then goes and takes
a spear and throws it at CL of black
killing him on the
spot so CL of black is now dead the two
men who are most responsible for
Alexander's victories in Persia are now
both
dead okay and he's become becoming more
and more of a
tyrant uh soon
afterwards there's a conspiracy there's
a real conspiracy to kill him what
happens is this okay uh the King
Alexander uh goes on a bore hunt with
his pages okay his servants now the
custom in Persia is the King has the
right to the first
kill but these are but his pages are
macedonians so they don't know this so
one of the pages is the first to kill
the boar Alexander is so angry he beats
the crap out of this page and the pages
get together that night and they resolve
to kill kill this
Tyrant and um they develop they they uh
organized a schedule so that on one
night they would be all in the bedroom
looking after Alexander while he sleeps
and then and then of course they would
take out their their dag stab Alexander
to death okay that's a plan what happens
is that night they were supposed to do
this act Alexander goes out drinking he
gets drunk and he does not come back
until the early morning when the pages
are gone okay at this point when the
pages gets nervous and tells Alexander
about the conspiracy and alander has
everyone killed okay but during the
trial the pages accused Alexander of
being a tyrant
okay does that make sense then what
happens is in 326
BC after xand has conquered all Persia
he decides to take his army to India
okay now his army is not happy about
this because look there are lots of good
reasons to invade Persia right the first
reason is Persia is very wealthy second
reason is um Persia invaded Greece right
so Greece so Persia was always a threat
to the Greece the Greek mainland the
third reason is there are lots of people
who suspect it was the Persians who
killed Philip okay so there are lots of
good reasons to invade Persia there's
absolutely no reason to invade India
okay they've never been to India they
have actually no idea what they will
find in India it's it's a different
Geography okay but in but Alexander
forces his forces his army to invade
India and basically modern day Pakistan
and there they win these
victories but the soldiers are really
pissed off because they're far away from
home they have AB no idea when this war
will end and the weather in India really
sucks okay so they basically Mutiny they
refuse to fight and Alexander at this
point has no choice but to give into the
but but to retreat okay to return back
to Babylon but he does two things to
show his anger the first thing he does
is he kills all the leaders of the
Mutiny okay those who spoke up on behalf
of their fellow soldiers were all killed
one by one second thing that happens is
rather than take his soldiers back um
the original way Alexander made them
through March through a desert which
killed many of them okay many died
because of dehydration and starvation it
was a brutal march across the
desert so
um Alexander takes his army back to
Babylon and at this at this
point um Alexander decides he can't
invade India so he'll go invade
Arabia okay he'll go invade Arabia which
is Desert there's a reason why no one
invaded Arabia and the reason why it's
all desert there's no reason to um
invade Arabia but alander wants to be
the first to conquer Arabia because his
ambition is boundless okay he has to
prove he's the greatest conqueror in the
world you only way we can do that is by
Conquering the entire
world he's very suspicious of his own
soldiers because they Mutiny against him
in India right so he's starting to
replace his army with Persians who are
much more obedient he wants
obedience then something else happens um
back in Macedonia the general in charge
interpreter who again is one of Philip's
most loyal um generals he gets an
argument with olympas okay
olympas as's mother and anpr don't see
either eye and olympius uh tells
Alexander and Alexander invites anetor
to Babylon where they will settle
matters okay and inor knows what
happened to pararan he knows what
happened to C of black and at this point
most of Alexander's generals are't
happppy the fact that the Army is being
persianized right they're being replaced
by Persian officers who are more loyal
to Alexander so um in
323 AER dies and again no one will ever
know what actually happened but the
theory is is this okay um I think the
theory that makes the most sense is
basically the top Echelon of the Mason
Army and temper and the other generals
basically decided Alexander has to go
because he's a
tyrant and eventually he's he's going to
kill everyone okay so uh what happened
was there was a banquet and's son his
son is the cup Bearer to Alexander the
the person who pours the drinks to
Alexander during uh meals the sun puts
poison in the
cup aand drinks from it and he starts to
vomit okay so Alexander leaves the room
to vomit and then the Sun at temperature
Sun brings a feather laced with more
poison to help exander vomit some more
okay but and so exander should have died
on the spot but exander is so tough he's
such a strong man that he lasts for a
few more weeks okay and he dies in bed
so Alexander now is
dead
okay okay this is important because
even though he's dead in in the 10 years
that he's been around he's been able to
conquer most of the world which includes
Egypt Mesopotamia Iran Afghanistan
Pakistan okay he's he's able to conquer
most of the known
world and this c a problem for his for
the generals who succeed him right
because once you conquer most of this
world and remember the plan was not to
conquer most of the world it was just
ander's balanced ambition that made them
do so okay now the question is how do
you
govern and so because of this pressure
they have no choice but to develop
something called Greek
culture and spread it in order to create
legitimacy for themselves okay and this
is this is something that we will talk
about next class which will conclude our
section on the Greeks okay the legacy of
Alexander he's conquered the world and
now his generals must govern it and to
govern it they must use something called
Greek culture so they must invent Greek
culture and then spread it around the
world and when they do so what will
happen is the Greek culture will merge
with local cultures to create new ideas
okay um Greek culture one of these
cultures that Greek culture will merge
with is called
Judaism
Judaism and when these when these two
cultures merge a new idea will
emerge from
this mixture called Christianity that
changes the world forever
okay that's why Christians love alander
the great because they feel that without
his Conquest Christianity could not have
been born okay so there are many
Christians who feel like ex the great
yeah he was a tyrant but he was part of
God's plan it was all part of a plan he
did what he did because he truly
is the son of Zeus Amon and Zeus
commanded him to conquer the
world okay all right but again that is a
Christian
perspective all right so that is it okay
so let's review what we did today we
basically looked at this an antical
model we made three predictions about
Alexander based on this anical model
right the first is that he would focus
on expansion second is he would become a
tyrant the third is that he would never
stop expanding
it turns out he was exactly like this
okay that this explains this predicts
his life and
times all right so um any
questions okay so um next class what we
will do is we will look look at um the
spreading of Greek culture and the
building of the helenistic world okay
and that will end our section on the
Greeks